I understand you were both just on
vacation someplace quite exotic where
did you go
Turks and Caicos who posted a Twitpic
this picture I'm told we're gonna show
it and the censors here said we can only
show it for three seconds but it is
pause home on DVR some creepy man it's
Bela creepy man you can show this for
three seconds so enjoy while you can and
go okay are you naked there I'm not
naked as you are you're naked well I
have a thong on but the booty swallows
up the thong so I'm actually not like
technically naked okay
it's just the angle you're at what was
the angle he was at he took the picture
and then you cleared it and said let's
send that out to the world
you're quite proud of your booty you
talk about your booty a lot and you say
that you were gift you're gifted in the
booty that's true I think everybody puts
it out on me that didn't I I mean I like
my booty but everybody likes it better
so I just happened to talk they see it
more than you do no one can see their
own booty I think she could see her as
if she looks over show
I like to give tips to the women that
want to get a little scrumptious rare
and and I that's another thing I do on
Twitter so not only do I like it I think
women appreciate the curviness so the
wit men I'm not gonna put that out there
but the thing is like women they want to
know how to get like a nice little tight
rear end so I think a lot of brothers
you need some but because that's the
impact area you understand me you don't
want to break a pelvis or anything you
did
[Applause]
I don't understand what's happening in
the next Olympics Allah yes